- [Chinedu] We're
dramatically disadvantaged
as a country because of
the impact of traffic.
The average Nigerian spends
hours every day in traffic.
We just don't have the infrastructure
to support the amount
of people in this city.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Here in Lagos, Nigeria,
traffic can get, well, pretty bad.
So two friends had
enough of waiting around.
They had a plan.
- I'm Adetayo Bamiduro.
- And I'm Chinedu Azodoh.
- And we're co-founders of Max.NG.
- Max is a mobile app
that provides Africans access to
motorcycle taxis in real time.
- And what we do is we train drivers,
um, regulates them,
and then connect them to customers
who need to move from
one point to the other.
We also connect those drivers
to individuals on business days
who have packages they want to deliver
from point A to point B.
- [Narrator] Chinedu and Adetayo met
while studying in the States.
They took a few classes together,
and both realized they wanted
to help their home country.
- While we were there,
we both had the passion to
transform and to change Africa.
We asked ourselves, you know,
what is the best way for
us to create a lot of jobs,
and what kind of problem can we solve
that would that would
make a lot of impact?
- [Chinedu] You see, Nigeria is
one of the fastest growing countries
from a population standpoint.
With the infrastructure that
we have available today,
motorcycles solve the problem.
You see, everything else
gets stuck in traffic.
A car gets stuck in traffic.
Buses get stuck in traffic.
- [Narrator] The motorcycles
allow their drivers to dart
in and out traffic easily,
thus saving time and being
able to make more deliveries.
So far, the company has
hired over 500 people,
and changed the lives of
many Nigerian families.
Chinedu and Adetayo
see it as their mission
to make a change in Lagos,
and the rest of Africa.
According to Max,
their drivers make two and a
half the industry average—
a wage that can set them on
a path to financial success.
- I am a Max champion.
- I am a Max champion!
- What we can do to make
life better for everybody,
we do that to the best of our abilities.
(laughter)